I feel the discussion again here thanks
thanks
so a couple of things before I start my
talk first is it's a great pleasure to
be here and thank you for the
opportunity and the second thing is I
along with my co-authors our economist
by training so I don't so there are at
least two implications of that one is
that I don't know many of you and so I
look forward to meeting you over the
next couple of days and the second is
that when I look at the slides of the
previous talks I realized that my talk
is a little too okay I'm very much less
illustrative danger talks who is almost
no graphics and so apologies in advance
for that so in this English paper this
paper is joint work with Ron islets and
kefir alias Sarang is at ben-gurion
University and kefir is at Tel Aviv and
in this paper what we want to do is to
introduce and study a Bayesian measure
of privacy loss most of a lot of you
have worked on differential privacy and
you know that it's a priori notion so
just as a quick reminder differential
privacy requires that the realized
outcome of a mechanism does not reveal
much about any individual participants
type but we think that this is mostly
from an outsider's perspective and I'll
explain what that means so if you think
about a mechanism that satisfies this
formal constraint of differential
privacy and when you go to implement it
you still need to collect people's types
and then map it to the outcome but what
if we worried that the person collecting
the types or the designer is not been up
in evidence enough what if we worried
that he or she might in this case know
too much about the agents information so
what we want to do in this paper is to
study mechanism design under a
for invasion version of privacy
constraints the limits how much
information the principal can get from
the agents through observing what they
do in the mechanism so to give you a
little more details we're going to
measure the privacy loss by how much the
principal learns by observing the agents
choices in the mechanism as when I said
it's Bayesian our principal is going to
start with some prior belief F about the
agent types he's going to offer a
general mechanism which is potentially
indirect and almost because of the
privacy constraint it's going to be
indirect and this mechanism is going to
specify a set of messages that the
agents can send as well as how these
messages are mapped to the outcome okay
so all of this is standard and then the
agents given the rules of the mechanism
will send messages and play in
equilibrium now the place where we
depart is to observe their given watch
these agents end in the equilibrium the
principal can form a new belief about
the agents types so the principal can
major updates and get information about
how the agent types are distributed
so we're going to define the privacy
laws as the expected distance between
the past year and prior beliefs as
measured by KL divergence okay and the
expectation here is over the messages
that are sent in your Calibri so the
exercise that we're going to do in this
paper yes that's a great question
actually I'll maybe after next slide the
answer will be clear the principle so
the exercising the paper is to assume
that there is a exogenous constraint on
how much how much privacy how much
information can be communicated through
the mechanism and under this constraint
we're going to solve for the optimal
mechanism so let me offer a cup of
discussion which will in particular
answer your question so the first point
to note is that this definition turns
out to be equivalent to the mutual
information between the types and the
messages and there is an early paper
there's an earlier paper by shell who in
the earlier version of the paper
considers this mutual information
measure but what he does is to impose
this as a cost to each agent instead
what we do is to take the viewpoint of
the regulator who is going to exhaustion
ously impose this constraint and so by
doing that we're now going to explicitly
model the agent preferences for privacy
well turn of lis if you wish you can
also interpret our model as saying that
each agent would like to participate in
a mechanism if and only if this
constraint is satisfied but that would
assume that agents all have the same
preference for privacy and it takes this
particular threshold for
the second point that I want to note is
that in this measure of privacy that I
defined on the previous slide the
measure basic takes the average across
different messages you can think of a
more stringent notion which we call
expose notion that requires that
regardless of what message is sent in
the equilibrium the principles
information gain does not exceed this
threshold
yes so let me go to the previous slide
for each realized message M there's
going to be a posterior belief and you
can calculate a KO divergence but these
messages are sent by different types
according to their equilibrium
strategies so the expectation is over
the messages with probability given by
the equilibrium strategies so going back
to what I was saying a more stringent
notion is to require for all messages
the information game does not exceed a
certain threshold as we show in a paper
the results for both cases are going to
be similar and in this talk I'm just
going to focus on the ex-ante case where
we take the average yes so in the in the
worst-case sense it is but the measure
by KO divergence is is different from
differential privacy right because I
think differential privacy you don't
have a prior to begin with what when I'm
even even in the ex post notion that
we're considering we're saying that
given your prior how much additional
information you gain from the mechanism
and we put a put a bound on that so
assuming that the prior is already very
precise than this this kind of
constraints would not have much but
I have a question about this is actually
related to that yeah so if you think of
this as a constraint that someone's
gonna verify mm-hmm
somehow the prior has to be specified as
part of the verification process and we
have to agree that that's like a good
prior or the right prior like how do you
like you know if I'm whatever company
that's trying to justify my mechanism to
a regulator and I say oh my prior is
uniform because I know nothing and they
kind of sign off and but that's actually
I actually have lots of other
information on the side like you know
how does that play into yeah so so I
think that's a good question in fact
that's something I'm going to briefly
touch on in the in the conclusion side
but I'm glad you brought it up already
so there is indeed an issue of when
actually implementing this the regulator
has to you know perhaps solicit the
prior from the principal and the the
principal may have an incentive to lie
so you know you can imagine a bigger
problem where where with where the the
prince the the regulator would take
taking two accounts that strategic
senseof and you know impose constraints
that would that would at least minimize
the cost of that we haven't we haven't
yet done that but I think that's a that
definitely a war swap direction to
pursue
okay and and then finally there's
there's this issue of how we aggregate
the privacy measure across different
agents what it would take the sum or
would take the worst case in the paper
so far we we're focusing on application
was only one agent so for this talk at
least will not worry about that so let
me let me talk about the specific
application which is basically the
screening mode of moosa and rosen so in
this model a seller is going to sell an
object to a buyer at some quantity or
quality level q and the buyer in turn is
going to pay a certain amount P to the
seller the buyer type we assume is
distributed according to this prior
distribution F and then once the
mechanism determines the price and the
quantity the profit is going to be
realized and then the eight the buyer is
going to get quasi linear utility from
this allocation we're going to make a
simplifying assumption that the prior
distribution f is such that the virtual
value is increasing and positive so that
in the classic model we would have
different types gets different
quantities and higher types would get
higher quantities okay and everybody is
getting positive amounts
now the difference in our model is that
the seller has to maximize profit
subject to the aforementioned privacy
constraints so to write down so that's
how we write down the constraint
optimization program again here we are
considering a general mechanism where
the messages may not be the types
themselves yes so so the the lowest type
wouldn't be zero in particular yes so
theta minus 1 minus 1 minus F capital F
theta divided by the density
case okay say it again I'm not sure I
understand what you mean by the reserved
[Music]
yes so the reserve price would be so you
you wouldn't set a reserve price you so
as I said the standard model would
predict them the sell the seller was
sell to everybody would I exclude
anybody by using a reserve price okay so
that's that's just simpler so in the
paper we can do arbitrary cost functions
but for the talk I'm just going to focus
on a quadratic cost function does any
convex function can be accommodated so
basically means they you know producing
higher the marginal cost of producing
additional quantity is increasing
so that's the monopolist production cost
yes yes
okay so the first mean result we show is
that
well given any finite capacity
constraint there exists a optimum
constraint mechanism where the message
space is just an interval partition of
the set of all types and in equilibrium
each type is going to report Dean chavo
to which in the NAS
now we also show some further properties
of the mechanism for example the
constraint is always going to bind in
any optimal mechanism and furthermore if
the privacy constraint is very tight
then it's optimal to use exactly two
intervals
so let me give some intuition for why
intervals emerge in our model the first
notes that there have been some papers
that explicitly impose an upper bound on
the number of messages that can be sent
in the in the mechanism and in this way
they're able to derive the optimality of
intervals for us the argument goes a
little differently the first thing we do
is to show that we can remove redundant
messages in the following sense so first
of all if two messages lead to the same
quantity then with our last we can
assume that they also lead to the same
price because the one with the higher
price will never be selected and
secondly we show that they can't even
lead to the same quantity in the optimum
because if they do then the principal
can combine them into a single message
without affecting the outcome of the
mechanism but what that would do is to
average the posterior beliefs from the
original two messages into a single
posterior belief and because the the
cost function on privacy is convex such
an average saves on the privacy measure
so in this way we can argue that
different messages are going to be
mapped into different quantities and
different prices so they can be wrecked
and then falling falling from that
different types are going to send
different types that send different
messages are going to partition the type
space and finally we argue that each of
these partitions is comebacks and so
they must be intervals and as you can
see this part of the arguments does not
quite rely on the specific form of KL
divergence in fact any function any cost
function that is convex in the posterior
beliefs will do the job however where we
do use the KL divergence is to show that
in in the optimism there are only
finitely many intervals and the
technical issue is that the spate
basically the space of partitions is not
compared so we cannot choose a
subsequence of partitions that find the
limit points etc etcetera what we have
to argue is the compactness can be
restored by showing that among all the
intervals the the principal offers there
can be a most one that is very short and
so that in turn will put an upper bound
on the number of intervals used the
reason there can be a most one short
interval is that if there are more than
one than they can be merged and it will
save enough privacy to enable a profit
gain by dividing another interval that's
relatively long so the intuition here is
is that the log term so recall that in
the payout divergence there is a log
term and that log term punishes very
heavily against precise information even
about a small set of types
that's the fundamental reason why there
can be at most one shorting scible now
in general it is a little hard to
pinpoint where the cut-offs of these
intervals lie but we can't leave do that
for the uniform distribution so assume
that the prior of biotypes is uniform
then we get Sakhi simplification that's
the ordering of these intervals in the
mechanism does not affect the profit or
the privacy measure and because of that
we can simply focus on the lens of these
intervals
so the characterization we get is that
for the uniform prior the optimal
mechanism is going to partition the type
space into all but one long intervals
which are equally long and one shorter
interval such that the privacy
constraint is exhausted make sure I
didn't lose too much are we considering
a case with many buyers and just one
person just yes just one buyer one
seller but if you think about a previous
result on intervals the same argument
extends to an auction setting
but so the end up right the expectation
again is over also over the type of the
person the distribution over tightness
yes so like if I show up and I'm up a
particular type maybe my privacy would
be violated a lot but only rarely yes
but if you prefer you can use the ex
post notion as I said the results would
be similar such that the original thing
that we want to do is sell to everyone
yes so why don't we just
and what we're only really doing is
selling to one person run from this
distribution so why don't we just post
the price that's the bottom of the
distribution why doesn't this mean your
privacy country yes so that's the case
where Kappa 0 that's that's the outcome
where you impose full privacy with no
privacy it's not optimal because there's
quantity it's not the the single units
case that you might have in mind in a
single unit case where it's indivisible
there's only two possibilities either
you sell or don't sell we're considering
a case where there's quantity of
quantity offered to the buyer so
different buyer types are going to get
different quantities in the standard
equilibrium
no no it's just a you demand a certain
good a certain amount right okay you can
think of K units but the but but the but
the seller has has increasing increasing
cost of production you can think of it
that way that's right that's right
yep so in the standard equilibrium
everybody's gonna get offered some
positive quantity but that's gonna be
depents but the exact unit number is
going to depend on the type yes so
that's one way you can think about it
yes so to illustrate the at least the
solution in the uniform distribution
case I'm drawing here the prop the
maximum privacy constraint profit for
the case of uniform prior prior
distributions that are uniform on one
two so what's interesting well the first
thing to note is that as we relax the
privacy constraint that is as we
increase Kappa profit always increases
that's not surprising at all what's a
little surprising is that it has these
kinks where the curve turns from convex
to being concave so where these kinks
are represents the point at which a new
interval is added to the optimum
mechanism recall from the
characterization that we said all but
one intervals are long but the other
last one is short but we didn't say how
many intervals are there it turns out
that the number of intervals involved
will increase as Kappa increases and
these discrete points indicated by the
kick and so in between these king points
the profit turns out to be convex as we
relax the privacy constraint but at
those kink points the profit change is
concave
so finally we show some results
regarding consumer surplus and total
welfare in this model something to note
is buyer surplus is well as you can
imagine in contrast to sell their
profits by a surplus is going to be
maximized with full privacy that is the
case where that is the case with a
posted price but under assumptions on
the density function the opposite
extreme with no privacy is going to
maximize the total welfare so you can
see there's a trade-off between
allocation efficiency and trying to
maximize buyer surplus per se so just to
quickly recap we we study the
implications of a bayesian privacy
measure and the main characterization is
that the principal will offer a course
menu in the form of interval partitions
now a couple of questions to think about
for the future include the actual
implementation regarding in particular
where does the power come from and
secondly we haven't really touched upon
the issue of multiple agents and how to
aggregate the privacy loss across these
agents and then lastly we focused our
static mechanisms but if you think about
dinette then the the distinction between
first price auctions and descending
auctions you will quickly realize that
dynamic auctions can save on privacy so
there's much left to do in that
direction as well
but that concludes my talk and thank you
[Applause]
so this is very risky what I do because
I will mmediately admitted I did not
follow all the algebra but I'm very
interested in the assumptions that are
there so I have the feeling that the
result is also an assumption to dare
extent that you're saying more
information about this particular buyer
will raise the profit less information
will know where the profit
this means that privacy is a cost and to
the to the seller now I think these are
assumptions in many ways because it
depends on so many different factors but
if you take that outcome as for instance
of policy then you're incentivizing
sellers to see privacy as a cost
function it also means that you do not
see privacy as an interactional or
relation or something I can imagine that
if buyers and sellers are in connection
with each other that a lot of the
assumptions that return in the outcome
or not have it anymore so I'm a little
concerned that the that the beginning
points in the end points are for a
number of reasons problematic because of
the incentives that are there in the end
situation and the assumptions in the
beginning that the algebra and reasoning
is completely correct I have to assume
that
so so for me then the question is by
thinking so clearly straight forward do
we lose sight of what betters and and
good could somebody who is much better
in computer science than me make make
that argument in a way that is
articulate for a computer scientist I
can immediately understand all the
reasons to say that this is [ __ ]
but I'm looking for a charitable
interpretation because I'm afraid that
privacy is here defined in such a way
that this will always be the outcome and
that's maybe not what we're looking for
without trying to ask a question so yeah
thank thanks for the question I think
it's a you know as as with almost all
models the the results are more or less
driven by the assumptions so it's a it's
a fair common Cystic to think more
deeply about what are the assumptions
make sense I mean what we have in mind
is situations like where this private
data is like ageing formation or house
information where certain firms can use
to to maybe targets to provide better
targeted services and make profits but
the government's may be worried that the
firm is going to get too much
information without any constraints so
that's the that's the perspective we're
taking obviously it will depend on the
application oh and I'm not I'm
definitely not saying that this is the
you know the one model - the only model
to think about privacy or anything like
that
but at least in some applications we
hope that this will be provide a useful
framework
so maybe just one question since you're
coming into a semester-long program
where many of us have spent a lifetime
privacy maybe you can do it but to more
specifically say why you wanted to
formulate a different notion of privacy
and the the crucial way that you see
here your measure differs sure
well the I guess to the first Ming
distinction is the differential privacy
wouldn't really have any bite in the
case of a single agent in the sense that
you know at least the way I understand
it is differential privacy requires the
outcome to be not influenced by changing
one particular person's report holding
other persons reports fixed at least for
single agent case that would not have
you know much impact but I think the
yes is that okay so it's Dec that gets
to the the actual application which is
if we're thinking about regulating firms
from collecting data from individuals
and in a way you know you know profit
maximizing way then off a lot a lot of
these applications are indeed with
single agents like selling house
insurance it's for example and so you
know at least we think this is one step
forward toward modern privacy that is
missing from the differential privacy
framework so I like your shift to focus
to the regulator too quick question this
one is do we have any reasons to think
we have a benevolent regulator
or do we what does it regulator need to
know in order to make sure that things
that externalities are checked and
related to that in one of your slides
you said that total welfare will
decrease to the extent that the price is
zero so I set the total welfare would be
maximized at no problem yes sir the
trade-off there could potentially be a
trade all right so I wonder that go to
the notion of assumption again that I
mean to the extent that there could be
externality so you have two agents and
that's it but perhaps you can answer
well as soon as we have more than two
ages and then that cannot be true right
because the whole point is that we if
you put a network connected through a
web then the privacy of those two
reflects on externalizes negatively on
others then the regulator should say
well clearly we have well some concerns
right so okay so I I understand I
understand that that comments and well
we don't have any reason we don't have
any concrete result more conquer is outs
in the multi agent case
and especially we haven't really modeled
the action ality of one's privacy on
other people's welfare so so that's you
know I don't have I don't have any any
of a complete answer to your question
but I think you know at least this
result per se is to at least say that
when the regulator let's say this kappa
can be chosen by the regulator then at
least this result would show that you
know in the ending varmints where the
model fits or roughly fits the regular
should think about whether you know
constraining privacy will hurts
allocation fittings efficiency by so
much that maybe it doesn't the regular
it doesn't want to do that but of course
there's a separate question whether the
regulator is benevolent or not and so I
think that in that regard differential
privacy is a really good metric because
it doesn't matter which which person's
sort of perspective we're taking right
here we're taking the perspective
regulator and obviously you know for
tomorrow we have to see him he's
benevolence but again there's a separate
question of even if the regular is
benevolent can he ensure that the seller
truthfully reports so I think there are
lots of open questions to be answered in
this space either in the differential
privacy framework or allow our framework
[Applause]